mais moi j'aurai fait du cinéma si
j'avais couché enfin deux fois vous
auriez fait du cinéma chez moi si
j'étais si je me droguais si je couchais
je serais déjà au cinéma sauf que je ne
fais pas donc ça prend du temps mais je
rendais compte ce que vous dites les
jeter oui mais c'est vrai comme on sort
qu'on est cool et qu'au congo ont fait
des câlins un peu à droite à gauche ça
va mieux depuis ses appuis donc voilà je
rate j'ai raté beaucoup de choses parce
que je mets je peux me regarder dans un
miroir
et pour quelques couacs
voilà catherine deneuve isabelle huppert
tous et le corps ici se sont également
dits passe à 6 passes a fait ça non
c'est une amie en fait ben oui paix et
annaba
j'avais demandé la liste
des noms mais je pense qu'elle n'a pas
connue par la mode ça je pense qu'elle
n'a pas complètement tort mais le dis de
manière un peu caricaturale et ça fait
un peu d'accord
ça fait du bien
elle dénonce à bien les jambes rattrape
[Applaudissements]
mais faut dire la vérité les promotions
canapé ça existe le cinéma la télévision
c'est des milieux où il ya des gens qui
ont beaucoup de talent et aussi des gens
qui ont moins de talent qui se retrouve
sous le feu des projecteurs et c'est
plate à elles sont très prisés et dont
il ya parfois des producteurs véreux on
l'a vu avec l'affairé one time oui je
vous dise ça pour quoi mettre des
plaques maladie
à raison oui mais moi je les trouve
sévère avec fabienne carat ils sont
hyper sympa mathieu pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle inventerait pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle mentir elle n'a plus d'intérêt
et elle est très précise elle dit avec
un grand réalisateur français il m'a
invité à monter dans sa chambre elle
raconte une histoire donc moi je la
crois tout à fait et c'est vrai c'est
vrai que vu son talent vu son talent si
elle n'a pas été plus loin dans le
cinéma c'est peut-être qu'à des raisons
donc je trouve que ce qu'elle dit sans
le vrai label voyez on peut aussi
énormément chez comme moi
daniel moi j'ai menacé de coucher pour
réussir
[Rires]
je pense qu'elle a voilà elle n'a pas
voulu dire ça mais cela veut dire ça
pourquoi la pression si on entend ce
qu'elle dit que toutes les actrices sont
aujourd'hui celles touchées et sont
drogués la façon dont elle le dit mais
je sais qu'elle n'a pas évidemment voulu
dire ça